identify 15 eighths or 15 over 8 as a
proper or an improper fraction or an
improper fraction so this is actually
just a good review of proper and
improper fractions and there's a pretty
easy way to identify them you have a
proper fraction if your numerator so
this right here is your numerator the
number on top if your numerator let me
just label a numerator and denominator
denominator nominate or you have a
proper fraction if your numerator if
your numerator is less than your
denominator if your numerator is less
than your denominator and if you don't
have a proper fraction you have an
improper fraction so your improper
fraction is if your numerator if your
numerator is greater than or equal to
your denominator and over here actually
that all the numbers are positive but if
you had some negative numbers here then
you would actually say the absolute
value of the numerator is less than the
absolute value of the denominator for a
proper fraction and the absolute value
of the numerator is greater than or
equal to the absolute value of a
denominator for an improper fraction so
let me just write that down just to be a
little bit just to be a little bit more
particular here because we could have
negative numbers in either the numerator
or the denominator anyway let's go back
to this problem 15 is clearly greater
than or equal to 8 so 15 is greater than
or equal to 8 15 is greater than or
equal to 8 so we are dealing with we are
dealing with an improper we are dealing
with an improper fraction